today
i announced my first proclamation
she got the throne empress catherine the
great
[Music]
i think a big theme of the show this
year is that she's becoming a mother
herself and also becoming a mother to
russia
[Music]
look at you
last thing
i call it the baby she's obviously
trying to juggle a lot it must be
strange a human creature inside you
do you ever think
what if he has a knife
i never do
and i don't think at first that
catherine necessarily takes to it very
odd to fear lungs being crushed like an
accordion into your throat by a foreign
invading creature who's taken over your
body i think if god really loved women
we'd lay eggs
catherine being pregnant is clearly a
feminist issue we almost done i have a
great deal to do it has not affected her
ability to rule in any way at all anyone
in the room may congratulate me on my
diplomatic victory
the growing creature within her is the
growing realization of what it means to
run a nation well you retire to bed now
empress no i have work to do that is why
i am here catherine's pregnancy affects
her strategy politically i have a busy
day running russia the country i just
took from you she knows that while she's
pregnant she's safe everyone expects you
to last a year i'm safe until the baby
is born there's heirs coming and someone
could take the baby and try and usurp
her power peter could come and slit my
throat and take over imprisoned until
paul is born you're a good dad look how
big you are how's paul we call the baby
paul my patience is wearing thin love
you
bye paul she's a very progressive person
in a very conservative
country that doesn't really want to
change let us remake russia my friend
so she's trying to bring enlightenment
to a country that kind of doesn't want
to change before she gives birth we must
act fast and show that i am a great
leader indispensable destined and loved
because she thinks after i give birth i
might die once paul's out someone will
try and kill you steal the baby and coos
both with it that's a big responsibility
people spilt blood for us and we will
repay it with sweat and toil catherine
is actually a contemporary woman
well done i will act decisively for my
country your arrogance is breathtaking
my ambition is breathtaking you actually
see her in different phases of pregnancy
with her growing stomach also you know
the pains of pregnancy oh did paul just
kick you yes all while she's trying to
lead
a country i need to rest not that she
can't do it all she can of course she
can because i am the future you have
never seen a ruler like me before i will
forge this country into a progressive
nation that electrifies europe in the
world as to what is possible god i love
your fire
you are a wonder
you